a moon as a other pitcher in shoreline
there I realize as I write has its own
myhnegon in myself country of swaps ker
I am ditch digger as far as drugs in
slopes Co it's pretty good
we are the green bounce and we have
American dream I find good job in Toccoa
[Music]
[Music]
it's been 100 years the pickle brine
preserved him perfectly it's really
doesn't the world has changed everyone I
know is gone you were able to track down
a great grandson are they they passed
away there was a car crash it will tell
me everything of them deaths how the
bodies died their faces is a life left
we will bond over our pain I understand
why you're a religious person but I not
how do you grieve for dead parents do it
ok idea we start the whole business
that's a very stupid idea
you have no I've no job no friends no
job yourself
I'm fine
will become success Wow very pungent hmm
yeah that's straight from the devil you
will finally make their parents proud
don't talk about my parents you never
met them you have captivated the hearts
of the entire world I'm probably not
best-case scenario for the family's
become an old company we have seen I'm
sure this is Asia well if man does not
throw punch because because these males
secretly pull the or don't something bad
[Music]
we're gonna join a sock whiskey Jew he
was it is this your father
no last David Bowie he'd be some mother
no that's also David Bowie that whole
posters David Bowie
[Music]
[Music]